i launched natural selections this week
the very first post
is called fact checkers aren't
scientists too often they're sensors
and the second one which is co-written
uh by brett and me
on driving sars kovi to extinct why we
need a multi-pronged approach
uh this is very we just published this
uh yesterday evening
it's very long sometimes technical not
as much fun as a lot of what i'm going
to be posting on natural selections
but it serves both as uh the response
to that um misinformation-filled
uh article that was published by
berlinsky and deegan and colette a few
years ago
and also to some degree by the response
to the sam harrison
eric topel podcast that uh we talked
about last week which
largely i you know they there weren't a
lot of errors
introduced by them that i think they
didn't pick up from the quality article
um so um this in in this piece
it is it is not the original draft was
really a sort of
a rebuttal but we decided you know what
this is this is not what we should be
doing this is not what anyone should be
doing
what we should be doing is laying out
what we see is the evidence what we see
is where evidence is missing where we
need
more why we need clarifications so that
all of us
can actually remember that we are on the
same team
on the same planet and that we need to
have
policies that actually serve all of us
maximally so far as that is possible
and so what we lay out here um are
really um i guess six six different
sort of organizational frameworks
organizational topics
we explain why why it is that we've
landed where we have
by going through the evidence for the
effectiveness
as of ivermectin as prophylaxis against
covid
the safety record of ivermectin the
safety record of the novel coronavirus
vaccines
and the effectiveness of the novel
coronavirus vaccines we then talk some
about natural immunity
and why people with natural immunity are
not being considered in the discussion
rather we have being presented by
the media for instance with these with
this simplistic
and frankly absurd dichotomy of
vaccinated versus unvaccinated
and we speak some to the politicization
of of the discussion
and um just a little bit more on some of
the some of the many errors that are in
um that are in some of the pieces that
have been produced
as if they are good faith criticisms and
you know as we
as we have said many times um
you know we we need we want everyone
should need and want good faith
criticism
but at the point that your critics are
making false claims about what it is
that you yourselves have
said or done or believe that should tell
you more about the critics than it tells
you about you
so yes it's one of it's one of two
things that i find particularly
disturbing about the critics is
having to portray us as believing things
and having said things that we didn't
believe
or don't believe and didn't say is
obviously
evidence of something and we can talk
about what it's evidence of but it's
clearly
you know uh having to defend against
straw man attacks is obviously uh crazy
making but there's also this question
about um the implications
right what we are being held responsible
for i find
uh particularly onerous and
uh destructive so in essence you will
find many people saying well
you know lives are at stake and what
you're saying
on your podcast is going to result in
the death of people and this is
um on the one hand
as we ourselves have said before anyone
else said it
about us obviously there are lives at
stake and so we take this very seriously
on the other hand
it is cheating to hold us responsible
for this
the correct honorable way to do this is
to recognize
that lives are at stake in the public
health policy questions
and your personal health decisions with
respect
to how you choose to protect yourself
from covid that
is true what that means is that a great
deal rests on how the evidence is
interpreted
and it is true you can certainly protect
yourself
from the accusation that you will be
responsible
for other people's um health
consequences
and possibly deaths by not saying
anything that's true you can simply not
say anything or you can
embrace the conventional wisdom as
dispensed by public health authorities
and then who could possibly hold you
responsible on the other hand
you've watched those public health
officials fail
again and again and again and we can
talk about why they might be failing
there are at least
two reasons on the table one of them is
incompetence
inability to read what is taking place
in the world
the other is corruption which is
something that you and i have talked
about
from the beginning and both of these
things
are rendering the advice we are being
given publicly
feeble so the question is what to do
about it
if you're in a position like we are in
do you talk about what you see
or do you keep quiet so is not to be
blamed
right now my feeling is we are morally
required
to the extent that we believe we can see
something that is failing about the
public health analysis we are morally
required to engage in talking about this
you are not required to listen you are
certainly not required to extrapolate
from anything that we say on this
podcast and adjust your behavior
you can just listen into a discussion
imagine it's a seminar taking place in
which we are
talking about whether or not the public
health analysis makes any sense
now if you find yourself persuaded by
something that we say
it may indeed affect your behavior but
that's because you have been persuaded
we don't have
the power to dictate any policy nobody
has to follow
what we're saying nobody has to listen
in so people are choosing to listen in
they are rightly frightened by the fact
that the advice they are getting from
public health officials
doesn't add up not even superficially
and so i would just simply ask it is not
the case that we are putting people's
lives at risk it is the case that lives
are at stake
in the coveted pandemic and that it is
true that lives will be lost if we do
the wrong things and not the right
things the question is
what are the right things and how would
you know
now what do you do in a case where you
have rampant corruption
and i do think one of the things that is
afflicting people's
comprehension of what's taking place
here is that many people
who have not been inside academia or
conversely are so
deeply enmeshed in it that they are
dependent on it are incapable of seeing
that the same corruption that has
rendered
our governmental structures so
thoroughly broken so that they do the
bidding
of others instead of the bidding of the
public that same thing is true
inside of academia more subtly it makes
its way into papers it makes its way
into analyses it makes its way
into the advice that we get from many
people who are involved
in that structure but you can't see it
and if it hasn't been your home
you don't recognize it so you think
somehow you think
everybody on earth must all be agreed
that the right thing to do is to drive
zara's kovi ii to extinction or at least
manage it really well and that must be
the source of all of this advice but i'm
telling you that can't possibly be right
it can't be what's generating this
advice because in many places
that that advice doesn't add up even
superficially
so there are certain questions that i
would advise you keep your eye on
certain things that tell you that
something other than public health or
private well-being is driving the policy
why are we argued why are we told that
we should vaccinate those
who are naturally immune as a result of
having had sars cov2
already that doesn't make any sense we
know that the immunity you get from the
vaccines is narrower
and we know that it uh fades we now know
that it fades
two why are we treating the young in
the same way that we are treating the
old with respect to the need to
vaccinate
there's obviously a very different
cost-benefit ratio and why are we not
using
safe tools that appear to have some
effectiveness to close the gap
left by the vaccines those the vaccines
can't reach those the vaccines
won't reach those who need treatment
because they have a breakthrough case
why wouldn't we use those things
all right you wanted to say something no
you moved on
um you sure okay
so i wanted to make a couple of points
the defense that we need is simply that
we are
trying to do the right thing right this
is well understood in the law there are
many places where good samaritans are
protected
for engaging in behavior intended to
help rather than harm even if harm is
done
that is the defense necessary for what
we are up to we do not
have some other thing motivating us in
fact we have
paid a very substantial price for
speaking out publicly on this topic and
we would ask
that you just simply recognize that
whether we are right or wrong
we are intending to do good and we are
also
interested as we make very clear in the
piece that we published yesterday
we are focused on the long-term
well-being
of humanity that means not just the
well-being of people who are alive today
but people who will be alive generations
from now who either will have to deal
with sars kobe 2 continuing to circulate
in some
new form or won't because we've
succeeded in driving it to extinction
that's a deep question we have an
obligation to them they cannot speak for
themselves we have to act on their
behalf
but the point is why would somebody
listen to us at all
well one reason that they would listen
to us is
that we have actually seen a head and
that if you listen to us you were ahead
on thinking about masks you were ahead
i'm thinking about
the importance of the volume of the room
in terms of uh
infection from uh covid you were ahead
in thinking about
variance you were ahead in seeing the
narrowness of the immunity that was
likely to come from
uh spike protein s1 subunit vaccinations
you were ahead in recognizing the
outdoor environment
as safe and some place that you should
go you were ahead in recognizing
the importance of vitamin d you were
ahead with respect to the lab leak
hypothesis
you were ahead with respect to the
massive significance of comorbidities
that's not even a complete list that's
just a bunch of places where if you were
watching us you were paying attention to
these things really early at the very
least and so
i will just finish this by saying
for some reason when we talk about
things like foreign policy we have a
term
for war profiteers right
war war profiteers nobody gets all bent
out of shape they don't accuse
you of conspiracy theorizing if you say
there are war profiteers and we need to
be aware
that they may have an effect on our
foreign policy that could push us into
wars that we would be better off
staying out of everybody gets that even
when there are lives
at stake in the context of war that
there are people whose perverse
incentives might cause them
to mislead us why do we not understand
that that same thing is at least
plausible with respect
to a pandemic are there pandemic
profiteers if so
what might they have us do that we
shouldn't do this is something
we need to ask ourselves and our ability
to predict things
is something you could judge us on but
you at least need to recognize
that we are in a landscape where
potentially people have perverse
incentives that might lead us to do
things that will result in
um in deaths that don't need to occur
if i can just restate in a sentence what
you just said profiteer is a general
category
and war profiteer is a subcategory that
is
well understood uh to be uh
to be out there regardless of whether or
not you believe that
you know incident x or y was an example
of it
uh war profiteering is a sub-category of
profiteering and so what you're saying
is um there are of course other types of
profiteering
and pandemic profiteering is likely to
be one of them
right it's likely to be one of them and
frankly it's not a very big leap from
what we've seen
from the pharmaceutical industry in
other contexts we know
that very often we see advice we know
that it makes it into the academic
literature and then is only later
revealed to be harming people
so come on what part of this is shocking
right the question is how much of an
effect is it having
on the public health advice that we are
getting and
one thing to pay attention to is the
public health advice
doesn't make sense right i'm not saying
none of it makes sense but a lot of it
doesn't make sense
even on its face why are we vaccinating
people who've had covet that's a
question i've not heard a good answer to
and the cdc's answer you can look it up
doesn't make any sense why is that is
that ineptitude
or is it corruption right could be
either could be both
but at some level it's a question that
needs an answer and until it has an
answer there's
there's some issue about how bad is that
rot
whatever rot it is that resulted in us
putting people
in harm's way giving them a vaccine we
don't know very much about with respect
to the safety
when they don't get a benefit from it
why would we do that well we could we
could prevent them from taking that risk
and the fact that we don't raises a
question how bad is the rock how far
does it go
and one indication is if others outside
of that apparatus are predicting things
about the pandemic
better than that apparatus does then
that is a reason for alarm
[Music]